hace un año el mundo del fútbol despidió
a diego armando maradona para muchos el
mejor jugador de la historia y un
personaje polémico por sus escándalos el
diego como le decían murió en una
vivienda a las afueras de buenos aires
en la actualidad hay siete profesionales
de la medicina acusados de homicidio por
la mala praxis y mientras que es su
herencia es motivo de una disputa pero
para hablar de el gran diego armando
maradona quiero saludar a una persona
que lo conocía muy bien el es jorge
burruchaga ex futbolista argentino
además compañero de selección de el
diego gracias jorge por estar con
nosotros en directo américa es para mí
un placer saludarlo y le quiero
preguntar a usted que que define a
maradona como un líder mundial explica
esto la trascendencia de su figura
qué tal cómo les va muy buenos días
desgraciadamente ya ya pasó un año de su
partida
desgraciadamente se fue cuando diego no
acostumbro en muchas ocasiones hasta las
bestias a las problemáticas que le
fueron apareciendo desde hace un tiempo
a esta parte
y bueno un momento que ya no pudo más su
corazón su alma
sin tranquilidad que venía pasando en
esos momentos
desgraciadamente hizo que dios de alguna
manera se apiadó de él
tranquilo en el lugar que por ahí está
con su mamá con su papá y uno de cerca
no lo recuerda de la mejor manera en un
momento vivido como compañeros los
momentos de las mundiales
la de un líder de extraordinario como
muy pocos en la vida de estos tiempos y
sobre todo en el fútbol y hasta parece
mentira que estemos hablando de un diego
maradona fallecido
también jorge a ustedes llamaron a los
une por siempre el gol de la final del
mundial de
1986 diego le dio a ustedes de un pase y
marcó el tanto de la victoria ese sigue
siendo el último gol de argentina en una
final de un mundial como lo recuerda que
hacía tan especial a diego jugando el
fútbol
y digo
con mucha gente obvio seguramente vos
también
para mí en lo particular y con todo
respeto es el mejor de todos los tiempos
y durar duda más allá que hoy en
argentina tenemos un mes y la
particularidad que lo hacía eran las
genialidades
y ni hablar del gol que que le hace a
los ingleses en cuartos de final de la
copa del mundo en una cancha deplorable
y gambeteando 67 singles solamente lo
puede hacer y el tiempo ese de
entrenamiento junto con todo lo que me
pedía bilardo en función de que yo
jugara
cerca de diego
hizo de qué
cuando él va recibió la pelota de
espaldas y te recuerda las imágenes y va
entrando de afuera hacia adentro le
gritó y no nos medio porque él estaba de
espalda pero bueno había mucho mucho
entrenamiento junto había muchos
automatismos pero más allá de eso había
la genialidad que él solo podría darte
un pase de espalda y
ponerme la por delante de mi carrera y
definir la copa del mundo así como estas
maravillas desde situaciones de juego a
los goles de láser bélgica también
fueron de una de una categoría
sensacional y única y creo que esos
jugadores que aparecen cada cada 20 30
años para su pelea pero sin diego y un
mes y para internarlo pero en este
sentido diego no sólo trascendió desde
lo futbolístico
trascendió también a través de su vida
de su pelea de sus luchas por la defensa
del jugador y después también fuera del
fútbol por por la vida que él eligió y
desgraciadamente uno ahí no se puede
meter porque cada uno elige
y quiere vivir
pero fue un genio por eso tengo que
tiene que estar permanentemente
concentrado y esperando que te puede
sacar te puede ser algo de la galera
como fue el pase ese que que termino yo
haciendo el gol y de sí mismo la copa
del mundo ahora jorge vamos a salirnos
entonces un poco de la cancha para
conocer a ese diego un poco más humano
usted que pudo compartir muy de cerca
con el cuál es el mejor recuerdo que
tiene de diego armando maradona y como
era con su círculo cercano como era con
sus amigos con sus compañeros de
selección
no yo
crea esa dicotomía de
es que se lo comparan en el jugador y en
su vida y ahí ahí hay quizás dos
diferencias muy marcadas pero yo me
quedo con la del futbolista con la del
líder con la del capital que de carlos
bilardo cuando subió a la selección
argentina lo puso a él como capitán como
nuestra bandera y en ese sentido te
puedo asegurar que era un tipo que
permanentemente estaba encima de todos
alentando
dando primero de todo haciendo doble
entrenamiento siendo siendo esos líderes
que por ahí en estos tiempos no abundan
no sólo en el contagio futbolístico sino
en una arenga
en algo por ejemplo una vez me hice
amigo mira que ahora vas a romper en el
mundial te lo aseguro vas a romper
imagínate para mí que diego me haya
dicho eso me
elevó al cielo y no es casualidad y sí
más edad mundial creo estoy convencido
que como futbolista fue reprochable
porque ha venido a jugar argentina
cuando el napoli el año 83 no le estaba
venir
era un rebelde que por la defensa de la
camiseta argentina hacía lo imposible y
no le hacía caso y hasta arriesgaba su
vida
lo hemos vivido hemos visto en
situaciones la copa américa el 89 no se
podría poder y sin embargo se infiltraba
la espalda para jugar un partido de
fútbol eso no lo hace cualquiera eso lo
hacen los grandes jugadores los grandes
líderes y principalmente aquellos
jugadores que cuando tenés la cinta de
capitán y estás por encima y sos el
referente de todo un grupo que tiene el
mismo sueño
también tenía una energía muy fuerte y
una espontaneidad increíble eso es lo
como lo recuerdan sus fanáticos en todo
el mundo sobre todo en argentina no sé
si usted ha tenido la oportunidad de
hablar con sus fanáticos de vivir pues
los homenajes que le han hecho a diego
que es lo que más resalta de esta
fanaticada que todavía pues sigue a
diego pues ese amor sigue por diego
si podría hablar con su fanático sabemos
lo que lo que piensa que dice yo digo me
dio hasta el 3 por eso dijo
hoy va a quedar
a través de su muerte y en este primer
año y lo que sucederá más adelante para
crear un mito digo porque bien para
todos diego bailaba bien y ver a un
actor fuera del fútbol diego dijeron
revolucionario y yo la mejor
valorización que yo hago dentro de todo
esto que diego hacía
fue cuando hizo súper tu partido
homenaje en cancha de boca con la famosa
frase que la pelota no se mancha y
principalmente cuando él dijo que se
equivocó el pago
vos sabrás que en estos tiempos desde
este mundo nuevo no mucha gente yo he
oído a gente y en esto y por otros
político ya todos deberíamos tener un
mundo mejor decir yo me llevo el país
sin embargo dios lo dijo como tanta como
tantas otras frase dios de una
ocurrencia ya un carisma exterior ni un
genio era un distinto dieron distintos
como futbolista era un dígito como
personaje era un distinto mismo estando
en situación el número habremos visto
su curación es gordo
tenían y me ha tocado la última vez que
lo vi en
un homenaje que le hicieron y en el cual
estuve tenían tenía un carisma que es
que yo miraba a la gente que lo miraba
era una conociéndolo habiendo hasta ocho
años cerca de él no obviamente ya no ya
no me sorprendía pero yo miraba cierto
eso es árabe como lo miraban era como
mirar un dios vivo que queda como como
ese mito que no sólo fue futbolístico
sino que también fue a su manera
revolucionario